hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast in vivo pet SPECT imaging of
human brain neuro sector systems three
decades of progress I am Brenda Kelly
Kim of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this presentation has been
approved for a category 1 continuing
medical education credit by loma linda
university if you are interested in
intake obtaining cme's after attending
this presentation please click on get
your free cme c ii credits button in the
bottom left corner of the event screen
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in green
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Dean one
dr. Wong is a professor in the johns
hopkins medicine department of radiology
and radiological science he also serves
as radiology vice chair for research
administration and training and director
of the section of high resolution brain
imaging within the division of nuclear
medicine dr. long received his
undergraduate degree in physics from the
University of Western Ontario and
completed his MD at the University of
Toronto in 1977 in 1980 he came to Johns
Hopkins as a research and clinical
fellow in the radiology division of
nuclear medicine he received a doctorate
and radiation health sciences from
hopkins in 1990 over the course of his
career dr. Wong has been a leader in the
design development and use of PET
scanning for the study of brain
chemistry he
been a primary investigator on numerous
federal and private grants has authored
or co-authored more than 200 articles
and 50 books chapters and essays and has
been an active consultant to
pharmaceutical companies in 2013 the
Society of nuclear medicine and
molecular imaging was stowed upon him a
policy aebersold award for outstanding
achievement and basic nuclear medicine I
will now turn it over to dr. Wang for
his presentation very much for that nice
introduction today I'm going to speak
about in vivo pet and SPECT imaging of
the human brain which goes over
approximately three decades of research
that was initiated all over the world
and I was just fortunate at my early
station career to be present during the
beginning of what really was a wave of
research that I'd like to share with you
today these are my disclosures and
they'll be online what I wanted to
indicate was that among the neuroscience
techniques there are a number of
techniques which have much higher
spatial resolution such as fMRI and
obviously confocal microscopy which are
indicated on this axis but the temporal
resolution as well is higher but the
specificity were studying the living
human brain and also a preclinical in
vivo brain is not really matched by most
techniques because of the neural
chemical specificity of the studies that
have been initiated with pet since the
early 1980s worldwide and
I'm fortunate to have been a small part
of that at Johns Hopkins which will give
you a little bit of background dog
what's important is that you're now
moving towards the millisecond range and
I'll very briefly talk about a an
initiative that we were fortunate enough
to get funded as part of the White House
NIH brain initiative at the end of this
presentation this slide indicates the
various techniques some of which you may
be familiar with in terms of function I
know that many of you are familiar with
fMRI and MRI PET inspect is a form of
functional imaging which allows us to
directly measure metabolism with a
higher sensitivity and typically a
higher resolution than magnetic
resonance spectroscopy and initially
blood flow pet was the really the gold
standard by which methods such as ASL
for mr are now taking place in the 1960s
and 70s oxygen and glucose metabolism
was the next role and then from 1980
approximately nineteen eighty-three
onwards studies in North America and
then all over the world began with
receptors and then subsequently pre
posted inter synaptic measurements and
so as part of pet and spect we study
your transmitters enzymes precursors and
more recently we were able to indirectly
measure the inter synaptic changes of
neurotransmitters themselves now this is
a picture to remind us that in the 1970s
and early 1980s as that was in its
infancy in its use in human beings
glucose metabolism was and still is one
of the important factors certainly in
neuroscience and as actually found an
even greater
or in areas of function including
oncology and cardiac studies and of
course since this is a neuroscience
lecture and won't talk about that but I
just wanted to indicate that what I'm
going to talk about today is not about
glucose metabolism but it's about the
next generation which has been going on
for the last three decades that's
neurotransmitter imaging in order to do
many of these studies we use
radiotracers such as carbon 11 and f-18
which have a 20 minute and 120 minute
half-life and these are as you know the
elements of life because many of the
important molecules biologically
especially in the central nervous system
include c12 and f-18 or a small
modification of it so show you in a
minute can be very useful for imaging so
because c11 and f-18 are unstable
radioactive substances we have to make
them in a what many you would refer to
in the old days as an atom smasher it's
a psychotron which makes radioactive
compounds like this and we got ours in
1979 I'm suffice to say that the f-18 or
the c11 typically our radio labeled to
thee to the compound of interest in a
minute I'll show you most of these
structures are 400 molecular weight and
they're basically antipsychotics and
antidepressants or derivatives of these
which have unstable c11 or f-18 these
two K as I said between 20 minutes and
120 110 minutes and when they decay they
give off a positive electron which only
travels about one to two millimeters in
in the body and of course in the brain
which is largely water there are many
stable negative electrons which make up
our body through the conservation of
energy momentum and
Mass the positive and negative electron
match up and they annihilate each other
and in order to conserve momentum they
give up to gamma rays 511 kill electron
volts and energy almost exactly 180
degrees together at the same time so
it's our ability to measure these two
sequences Sam almost simultaneously that
gives us the highest sensitivity and
specificity of pet for neuroreceptors
here's an example of just a single case
where a positron say from a labeled
antipsychotic reaches a electron which
is say in brain water as soon as they
match they give off the 5-11 KETV
photons which then are measured by two
detectors at 180 degrees to one another
if the electronics detects these within
a very short window and now there are
those scanners that can allow
measurements for time of flight so it
can actually detect the slight time
difference and and then figure out where
this came from this can then be used in
the following way after you get many
millions of these coincidences at
various times in the brain we can then
see that each pairs of detectors can
electronically determine where these
measurements are now how does this
differ from CT scanning well raciti
scanning as you know we give an x-ray
through the brain and then they measure
detectors in a ring in this case the
radioactivity is giving out 511 KETV
photons which initiated from the
unstable positron and it's the ability
to measure these many many pairs that
the death then can then be back
projected to the brain and figure out
where the brain chemicals are in three
dimensions we are fortunate to have one
of the 18 highest resolution
commercially available PET scanners in
the world at Johns Hopkins
and this is the HR RT which currently is
being overseen by is being maintained by
the Siemens company and this has many
many millions of coincidence at any time
it has it has the ability to provide as
much as two millimeter resolution images
so as you can see here this is actually
a a green monkey that that is only four
kilograms and you can clearly see the
putamen and caudate in these sagittal
slices and in the human brain this
happens to be a glucose measurement you
can clearly see the cortex and the
internal capsule and other structures
here on this FD in on this fdg patient
which almost looks like an MRI scan
because we have approximately two
millimeter resolution we actually in
this scanner have 207 axial slices the
typical PET scans prior to this
generation of scanner might only have 15
to 30 and we have 207 so we can cover
the entire brain and this just happens
to me an example from a possible the
rest is to raise poor ligand that
measures with c11 rolipram all these
different slices so one can cover the
entire brain and part of the cervical
spine the acquisition reconstruction and
backup of these studies are complicated
and they involve not only acquiring all
these various interactions but the
reconstructions can be as much as as 30
gigabytes of data at one time and but
we've managed to accelerate this using
special computer clusters so the
reconstructions can take place within
four hours four to six hours the
original first HRT took one week to
reconstruct a 30
dynamic study so you can see we really
progress as computation and fruits now
this is the key to what we're doing
today and I ask you to please look at
this there are two papers that are
important from the 1970s that I think
you should be where everyone is my
Philip semen from the pharmacology and
psychiatry department at the University
of Toronto and the other one is by Saul
Schneider from our own neuroscience
Department here at Hopkins and they show
similar things this particular one shows
on this axis the in vitro binding
affinity measured by the ic50 and for
those of you who are not so familiar
with binding affinity what that means is
it's the the amount of a drug that's
needed to to block fifty percent of the
binding of a trace of a of a true dat
tracer so in this case it was attributed
haloperidol believe against all of these
different unlabeled antipsychotics and
in the 1970s these were the the whole
bunch of them so for example the
original one chrome promazine and
chlorpromazine is up here and it had the
lowest mind infinity and on this axis is
the range and average clinical dose for
controlling patients with schizophrenia
and milligrams per day what I find
fascinating about this slide is that
this is still useful today even in
second and third generation
antipsychotics which have different
antipsychotics on them and even in
antidepressants and other disorders and
so that the neuroscience of
neuropsychiatric drugs are that there
seems to be a formal relationship in
this log log plot between binding
affinity in the test tube and actual
controlling of some of the symptoms of
schizophrenia now of course these are
only some of the symptoms we still don't
have the ideal drug for schizophrenia
which which I'll talk about later why
we're working on this area but
nevertheless for many of the positives
and Crips of skits are
rania such as actor bruce emissions and
delusions even back in the 1970s this
relationship occurred the compound that
we first started with and not only we
but there were at least two or three
other groups in the u.s. focused on
spiral pyridyl which was a very high
affinity and as you can see very potent
drug for controlling schizophrenia but
like so many things in science there
were complications and i'll come back to
that in a second that stripper um
allowed us to label d2 receptors and now
this is just a partial list of the many
areas that we can look at from dopamine
serotonin opiates nicotinic alpha or
beta two of the seven histamine
norepinephrine and all and and and and
what I haven't put on this list is
things like cannabinoids and glutamate
which I'll talk about towards the end of
this lecture this is a picture courtesy
of my colleague heroic Rivera at Hopkins
that shows a whole list of binding
potential maps for example in dopamine
d2 in in terms of dopamine opiates all
the various types this is a omar and
other compounds serotonin transporters
so many of these compounds all done in
human beings as well as over the last 30
years so how did we get to where we're
going now well we were fortunate there
are many groups trying to florin a stiff
room which i showed you earlier was the
most highest specific highest binding
and at that time seemed to be one of the
most potent antipsychotics but we had a
nice collaboration with between Bob
dolls and Bank Langstrom make links from
from upsala University in Sweden and
bank and Bob had the
iya that instead of labeling the
fluorine which is difficult they tried
to label this entire molecule by adding
a methyl group spit barone itself does
not have this methyl group and so that's
why it's called n-methyl cipro in the
three position and since we can makes
c11 met an FOI guy in with high amounts
of radioactivity so that most of the
atoms are labeled with carbon 11 between
Bob and bank they were able to in
nineteen eighty-two a nineteen
eighty-three radio labeled pneus and
create this molecule and then through a
lot of preclinical testing we confirm
that this is labeled d2 receptors the
same way that it was a bit stiffer on
itself would label and in the past
stripper own entry dated version alone
without the methyl group was actually in
the early late 1970s and early 1980s the
prototype tracer for in vitro studies
now it's replaced by many compounds like
aqua pride and others but in those days
this was the specific one now later on
other groups labeled fluorine-18 and
flora methods for prone and others and
and the rest is history so we were
fortunate at Hopkins that I was just a
student then perhaps at the level of
many of you who are listening in now and
my former mentor Henry Wagner who passed
away about three years ago he he
volunteered to do the first study anime
1983 this was the radio labeled stripper
on showing the basal ganglia for d2 and
d3 like receptors and the cortical
regions which are primarily 5-ht 2a and
alpha adrenergic you now have much more
specific compounds but it worked and
we're able to move forward with this
study and so this is if you want to read
about it it's from Wagner Adele Wagner
burns down some wrong from 1983 and
I was fortunate to be part of this as a
student in a trainee I had a little more
hair at that time and then exactly one
year later one of my colleagues Jim
Frost and saw Snyder the the the most
recent director of the neuroscience
Department in at Johns Hopkins and
masonic snyder department of
neuroscience and now Rick hugin area is
the chair but he came to the pet center
because he was his idea to radio labeled
a derivative of fentanyl and soak our
customer was made exactly one year later
and the first imaging of the opiate
receptor occurred and of course we were
able to block both this compound with
naloxone and this compound with
haloperidol and i'll show some examples
that later so here is an example of the
dopaminergic system that shows all the
things that we can label and here we see
that not only did it start with labeling
postsynaptic receptors such as the d2
like receptors of slipper room but
around the same time in 1983 the group
at McMaster University in Hamilton
Ontario developed radio labeled floor
dopa and this allowed a measurement of
dopa decarboxylase now fast-forward 30
years we can routinely label the bnet
transporter of the vesicles in fact some
of this is going to become eventually
commercially available we believe in the
u.s. we can we in the 1990s we developed
with Michael kuhar at Emory not only
stripper on but the radio labeling of
the dopamine transporter whereas you
know cocaine and and other and
methylphenidate and ketamine can act in
part and
and it's the reup tech site for
endogenous dopamine and so that was
labeled with a cocaine continent and
then more recently as I'll show you in a
minute even though we cannot measure
dopamine directly we can measure the
degree to which dopamine displaces
radiotracers finding either to the
transporters or to the postsynaptic
receptors which gives a measure of inner
synaptic dopamine here is a picture that
shows what actually can be done as this
is a two-day study that was done in
Tourette syndrome as well as restless
leg syndrome where we were able to
measure a high specific activity
rockville pride that means that most of
the radiotracers molecules are labeled
with carbon 11 and then we added carrier
or unlabeled Rockville pride and you get
two points on a scattered to measure
receptor density we measured on the same
day in the absence and presence of an
intravenous and feta me challenge of 0.3
milligrams per kilogram given five
minutes before the second injection the
dopamine release that I referred to and
then on the second day we were able to
measure the dopamine transporter using
this superscript 11 see when 35 common
for 28 which we developed with my cool
run so in one day in two days we were
able to do dopamine receptor density
dopamine release and dopamine
transporters in other words we could get
all of these things here in just two
days and that's a typical example of the
power of this tool now my colleague and
friend Tony Grace who was kind enough to
invite me to be part of this wonderful
webinar has worked heavily on the role
of tonic and phasic dopamine in his many
research
areas and hypotheses about
neuropsychiatric disorders including
schizophrenia and substance abuse
suffice to say i'm sure you've heard
about this from tony already but the
tonic dopamine or the endless emails
stasis dopamine is more extracellular
and more a stable level and so for
example dr. grace believes that there's
a in schizophrenia there may be a
reduction of dopamine due to high
falutin Mukherjee changes which
downstream changes tonic dopamine and
then that that change which might be
more of a trade than state situation
results in this this trait of the state
issue where when you have a changed
dopamine level for tonically you lower
the brake or you lower the amount of
ambition of phasic dopamine and phasic
dopamine is what we believe correlates
with burst firing of the VTA and in
particular dr. grace believes that this
phasic dopamine which we might attribute
to positive symptoms of schizophrenia or
some of the the positive acute effects
of reward like opening may in fact be
measurable with pet as I'll show you in
a minute so this brings us together the
tonic and phasic story and again phasic
dopamine we think is related to the
measurement of inter synaptic dopamine
that I mentioned a couple minutes ago
whereas the tonic go from me it's a
little harder for us to measure with pet
or we think that controls how much
dopamine is released either in
behavioral states or in the presence of
pharmacologic challenge so I want you to
remember that when I talk about phasic
dopamine in the pet studies you'll have
a molecular picture looks going on and
in the end this may be in fact it's at
least in schizophrenia affected by the
main system now one area that I've had
the opportunity to work in is Tourette
syndrome and you can read about this in
our 2008 neuropsychopharmacology paper
and this shows that when we do an
amphetamine challenge we're actually
able to demonstrate when we give him fed
when we give about 3.3 milligrams per
kilogram of abeta me we're able to
demonstrate that we have release of
dopamine that occurs here compared to
the controls which is the more of red
bars and in patients with comorbid
Tourette's which happens at least twenty
to thirty percent of the time in people
with director is even a greater release
so we think that there is a combination
of these make affect the ability of
phasic dopamine furthermore more
recently we've been studying OCD
subtypes and we find that people with
Jerry nest at of our Center who's an OCD
expert and we find that that people with
OCD aggressive and symptomatology as
compared to those people who are more
concerned about germophobia etc there is
a big difference between the amount of
and feta meany induce dopamine release
in the presence of whichever OCD subtype
they have now what about behavior
stimulation in behavioral stimulation we
there has been a literature even going
back to the late 1990s the dopamine
release can be changed potentially by
Hughes and I'll show you evidence in
this minute and we're different
dopaminergic parts the basal ganglia are
active during early exposure to reward
when reward is unpredictable are
familiar with the Wolfram Schultz
hypothesis and finally direct evidence
was shown
by the Gaspee group in London that that
when video games were shown to young
boys doing an escalating video games
they had more and more release of
dopamine so here's a SPM roxa by voxel
map showing the brain areas that lit up
when young boys played a video game as
they got higher and higher in that video
game process now this is a study that we
did in collaboration with edith london
and the NIDA intramural program in
Baltimore and we published in 2008 and
this is kind of exciting because we
showed craving audio-visual craving
capes to diagnose subjects with cocaine
dependence and we know that about fifty
percent of people that are shown craving
cues that is paraphernalia and pictures
of active drug use such as in Baltimore
anyway it's making up smoking snorting
or intravenous injection of cocaine and
there was a videotape that dr. London
and I used that originally came from
Steve grants who published a study in
MTG a few years earlier also with nida
but in this case we did we wrap up right
measurement which is known to be
affected by inter synaptic dopamine and
in this case you can see we have a
amount of release of dopamine that is
the displacement of dopamine in the
presence of these craving cues in those
people that did crave and it's about
fifty percent in Baltimore but so about
fifty percent are down here but the
percent we did great they all gave
visual analogue rating scales of their
craving in the PET scanner and as you
can see there was a direct relationship
between craving and dopamine release or
inter synaptic dopamine which we
think relates to phasic dopamine notice
and a similar finding was found by nora
vocab the director of NIDA with her
colleagues at Brookhaven in the same
year now I want to say something about
pet and it's world in drug development
as many of you know unfortunately there
has been a for the development of
psychiatric drugs especially and to some
extent neurological drugs because less
and less are being developed world ride
and especially in the u.s. because the
risks are very high and the costs are
very high and even now of course we have
virtually no drug that is successful
long-term for Alzheimer's and many of
the drugs for the other nature for major
psychiatric disorders the number of new
drugs being developed our smaller and
smaller each year and so this is a slide
from Steve Paul who's now at Cornell and
what's at lily many years ago and he
suggests that this is the traditional
route and the cost of developing a drug
which is about a billion dollars but one
way of reducing the cost is between the
preclinical level and early phase run to
try to kill off those drugs that are not
likely to make it well pet fits right
into this space we actually help
determine those levels and drug levels
and and determine which drugs should go
on to the next step here is an original
example of this donor our Center where a
subject receive n-methyl script room
with the binding to the basal ganglia
and in the presence of about eight
milligrams of haloperidol given four
hours before the PET scan you can see
there's a big degree of occupancy or
blockade this is just like people
filling up a stadium at the Super Bowl
or filling up a hotel in a during a
convention and it turns out that Lars
faridah and his team at the Karolinska
using wreck with regular record pride
was invented discovered this almost
axiomatic diagram
least for first in general and
second-generation antipsychotics in
schizophrenia and that is that it can
get to 100% occupancy and as I showed
you a minute ago this is close to about
eighty percent occupancy seventy percent
occupancy they should get close to one
hundred percent occupancy and and you
look at this against me the oral dose of
antipsychotics because of course
antipsychotics are given orally or by
Depot injection we found that if the
receptor occupancy by pet was between
seventy and eighty percent that that was
the sweet spot and that when you gave
higher doses we would actually increase
the number of extrapyramidal symptoms or
side effects when you went lower it was
not as efficacious and the only
exception to this is the mystery close
being where we still don't know exactly
watch shuttle down in a second I'll show
you where this curve is shifted over
with newer drugs like in our proposal
this is aripiprazole it used to be
called OPC then but it's actually this
is a vilified and this is a study that
was published a few years ago with Katie
FSE air and now Katie Smith from otsuka
at that time the baseline Rockville
products can and this 2 milligrams per
day in normal role in tears after 14
gauge you can see there's a large
blockade and what we found is of course
this curvilinear occupancy and this is
the expected dose range as predicted by
large parties earlier work but what we
determined was that the clinical use
those for Villa fire aripiprazole here
it is their purpose i was actually
closer to ninety to ninety-five percent
so why is it that era aripiprazole
required this level of dose whereas
other antipsychotics such as first and
second-generation antipsychotics only
required sixty to eighty percent well
the answer i think may have already been
addressed in part by professor arvid
carlsson who has developed his own
compound
and in both air proposal and his
compound are believed by many to be
partial agonists of dopamine as well as
having dopamine d2 and other antagonism
and in the presence of such dopamine
partial agonist you have to push the
dose higher but the advantage of the
partial agonism is that the number of
side effects that occur at the higher
doses seem to be a little lower and so
PET scanning can explain both the lower
dose used by first and second generation
drugs the slightly higher dose that
might be used in drugs like air parasol
and other goes drugs such as in second
and third generation where there are
more than dopamine that are factors such
as serotonin and other place and we
won't have time to go in that to that
today one of the areas that I think is
extremely important to to be to our
society because of the important rule of
marijuana and THC there's a great debate
about its world in medical marijuana but
we also know that there are still
definitive issues that cause they give
us concern in terms of its widespread
use and so I'm not of making a political
statement I'm simply indicating that we
now have the tools to investigate the
cannabinoid cb1 system and this was done
in collaboration with my colleague and
authority who helped invent these
compounds this is the THC and the cb1
cannabinoid system and cannabinoids are
tightly related to dopamine and there
are a number of studies showing the
effects of cannabinoids causing dopamine
changes which of course ultimately
really to reward we also know for the
work of many here's a study from de
Souza showing that patients with
schizophrenia have enhanced sensitivity
t cube
and we also know of course that there is
a app ademia logic study including those
by robyn marie and others that earlier
use of THC may result in some increase
epidemiologic evidence for earlier
probability of psychosis in some
populations and any event the point is
that you the THC has a two-edged sword
it can be it could very well be very
important for medical marijuana and for
oncology studies but it also has other
issues but it also can be useful
therapeutically as I'll show you in
areas like schizophrenia so right now
there are multiple traces use for
studying cb1 and this is the one we
develop which is now called Omar and I
wanted to use this time to just explain
to you how pet racers are developed
briefly the way it happens is you have a
hypothesis in this case we can measure
cannabinoids we have to come up with a
chemical development like I showed you
with Bob Hamilton did it with nf2
stripper own years ago and then we can
either do i Odin iota Nader and
technetium which is called single photon
emission tomography I won't have time to
talk about that today or we can use
carbon 11 or f-18 which we develop in
our in-house psychotron we then have a
preclinical development that has to go
through rodin by distributions and an
initial estimate of radiation dosimetry
these tracers have exquisitely low
radiation burden and in all the research
studies we amount of radiation is well
below with radiologists in the United
States including people like me are
allowed to receive occupation we are no
additional risk we have no additional
morbidity or mortality than any other
medical specialty in fact and so these
are these are extremely low dose and
essentially in men
radiation burden but nevertheless we
have to determine this in animals and
then we go on to test these if they seem
to work in animals in non-human primates
all of the primates that we study have
been around for 10 or 15 years they are
they are very well taken care of and we
simply do a mild anesthetic to image
them but they're very predictive of what
goes on to a human and then if they look
promising in say in a baboon or primate
monkey study we can then go on to
develop the requirements from the FDA
and the local women subjects committee
including quantitation using kinetic
mathematical modeling to develop these
traces and we do eat it with pet or
respect here's an example with the
cannabinoid Omar where you can see the
regional distribution in mice and this
is in brain regions important that
cannabinoids and these are areas that do
not have as much activity cannabinoid
binding and then you can see the the
ratio which is some indication of
specific binding and here with self lock
a door with other drugs such as
conceiving one antagonist such as romana
Bach we were able to demonstrate both in
the unblocked and block state the
specificity in multiple brain regions I
should consider cerebellar cortex
hippocampus etc and thalamus and in this
case Romana bot is a is a drug that was
developed originally in Europe and was
never never received the go-ahead here
but it was very close to a drug used for
schizophrenia and we worked on
derivatives of that with companies for
schizophrenia
so it has been useful these these remind
about derivatives have been useful as a
potential antipsychotic and they have
also been useful for reducing eating
urges and has been a target for obesity
and it's still an important target so
the cannabinoid system has many medical
beneficent visual aspects which can be
examined with pet and this shows the
next step these are the pet data that we
have here correlating with the known
binding of the tracer in post-mortem
human autoradiography so you see they
seem to correlate reason to grow this is
a non-human primate study of Omar it was
called Omar subsequently that's the
original JQ number and these are pet and
MRI studies showing the binding Cooper
Cayman and other areas in the axial
slice in the baboon and in the sagittal
slice of eberron brain and then in the
presence of romana bot one milligram per
kilogram you can see there's the
significant blockade of the tracer in
both these slices and then once we were
able to establish that this tracer who
work in the nonhuman primate brain we
were confident to proceed with the
requirements to grow into humans and
here's an example of the intensive taken
the cingulate cortex in the human brain
we found that a measurement of the
binding is called the volume of
distribution and there was a regional
specificity expected throughout in
normal volunteers and then we also found
as is the case with most compounds and
we were fortunate to show the in 1984 in
we demonstrated the in vivo the first
suggestion that d2 receptors might fall
with age now it seems to be the case in
almost all neurotransmitter systems
between the ages of eighteen men
and we would go up to as much as 70 we
see this in multiple brain areas in
Globus pallidus cingulate from a cortex
and these are just the prediction limits
associated with that regression line one
of the interesting findings we had
though was when reciting patients with
schizophrenia we noticed that when we
use the brief psychiatric the bpr pprs
the brief psychiatric subscale with four
negative symptoms that is an adonia and
lack of motivation and other issues that
which is the most challenging area for
aesthetic or developing schizophrenia
drugs that we were able to see that the
pet binding correlated inversely with
this suggesting there was an important
relationship between cb1 receptors and
negative symptoms giving us a clue for
the next step of what might be helpful
in some of the drugs from schizophrenia
now I want to quickly go through the
metabotropic system because this is a
very important area in neuropsychiatric
disorders and we know that the glutamate
and lacing system are have many
connections and glycine itself it's
important that i'm going to talk about
that here trying to glue to make glycine
has been linked to the NMDA receptor to
schizophrenia and many people try to
increase glycine by giving glycine
surrogates across the blood-brain
barrier but the problem is that they
don't go across the border very well the
embro r5 system is one of the most best
developed systems along with n grow are
two and three but n grow are five is the
one that we now can study with bet and
it's important schizophrenia depression
and other disorders on MGO are five is
actually a target the committee of you
may know in fragile x including most
models of fragile x one of the autistic
spectrum syndromes reducing mboro are
five expression rescues fragile x
syndrome
so measuring and low price is very
important in development and here a
number of compounds that are available
we were with Ricky Waterhouse when she
was at Merck and with the merc group on
developing through an NIH grant one of
these f peb compounds which was a
derivative Merck head and then we took
it to the public space through an NIH
grant through ni-mh and we also looked
at c11 abp which is a member or fob
compound developed in in Zurich and from
the Novartis company and the University
of Zurich and here you see fragile X
within our own fragile X model and
Hopkins we showed that fragile X was
increased compared to the wild type
using Road repent studies most
importantly without my Oscar and Jeff
Rothstein of the ALS Center at Hopkins
we looked at ALS mice and you can see em
roar five surprisingly has an elevation
in ALS mice which is especially bad in
chronically ill but so we're doing this
in him itself and then this is the embro
r5 system in normal humans now I said
the glutamate and glycine system are
linked but most importantly instead of
trying to get glycine to cross the
blood-brain barrier glycine transporters
are being used to block and increase
through the mate and so to measure this
for so-called target engagement we
worked with a daily Baronia groche and
his colleagues in basel developed to pet
leggins and this is the autoradiography
that showed these compounds would work
we study two of them at the same time in
papio anubis baboon brain and we picked
one and the one that we picked went on
to the study preclinical II
and it turned out that we did an
occupancy study the occupancy that we
thought matched what was done in animal
behavior studies was about forty percent
and that forty percent occupancy seem to
match directly with what they found was
the optimal delayed to match test
preclinical e in Roche we then went on
to develop a human compound which you
can see here with the glycine
transporter and then with the Roche
colleagues we did occupancy studies with
vital piriton rg1 six seven eight and
here are different studies showing
neuropsychopharmacology showing that at
different dose levels including shortly
after the administration of the drug and
then several hours later we're able to
demonstrate a dose response curve as you
can see here here's in one brain region
and here's the dose or up this is the
dose of the drug orally and this is the
pet occupancy and what's most important
about this is again the forty percent
occupancy that we looked at seem to
match at that time the results they were
getting a phase two that is the phase 2
studies matched it so in a sense for pet
and occupancy work so finally I'd like
to briefly talk about amyloid because
this is very important because this is
our the next frontier and the first
study that was developed was the
Pittsburgh group who developed
radioactive dies with the Pittsburgh
compound be done about a decade ago and
using this Susan Resnick and others at
the nationís to the Beijing of them
longitudinal studies showing the
different ages cross-sectionally the
increase of amyloid binding and then
longitudinally many studies and this is
just one from the NIH ni a Baltimore
lunch
studying showing that even over a period
of just a couple of years there's an
increase of amyloid accumulation that
can be seen in people at risk for
schizophrenia for Alzheimer's and
neurocognitive impairment now f18 110
minute compounds have been developed
because they can be distributed to
places that don't have Cybertron's so
here's three of them and the one that we
first developed at hopkins with abbott
which is now part of Lilly was a V 45
this is the first one developed by eight
called a beer on this is a the second
one this was one develop about the same
time by GE through many milk first in
Europe and men in the u.s. you studied
here and this is the one we develop them
you can read about it in the journal
nuclear medicine this is a patient with
Alzheimer's and mrs. a normal control
showing the right matter uptake but all
the gray matter particle uptake in
patients without summer so these are now
used routinely for the edge summers
disease neuroimaging initiative number
two ADNI for ongoing federally a
private-public relationships with harlem
and so this was picked in part by our
collaborators that added because it was
a nice point where the alzheimer's and
the controls after about 40 minutes
showed a nice separation and we also
study GE not only the avid compound was
correlated with postmortem studies and
those patients that passed away shortly
after standing but also we work with
lamentable when GE correlating in vivo
brain biopsies used for people with none
normal pressure hydrocephalus and then
the last two slides just to mention that
t SP 0 ligands have been used for narrow
information my colleague Tom Gilardi is
now at Columbia including brain injury
and neural information and finally I
just wanted to mention that we were
fortunate to receive a planning grant
from the brain initiative the NIH the
White House and actually this is a
series of collaborators we are now
studying in dville neurotransmitter
modulation
a real time remember I said it took
somewhere between 60 and a hundred
minutes to scan a typical human or
non-human primate we are now working
with universal copenhagen and an
university of connecticut and others to
develop voltage-sensitive dyes which
which release fluorescent light which
can be give us measurements of ideally
electrical activity in the millisecond
range so here's an example where light
is Sean in and then it and then it's red
shifted and we can measure that through
external detectors and working with Tony
grace we hope that we can extend the
known electrical activity two marow
pharmacologic changes which dr. grace is
an expert on so what we envision it
might happen is something like this now
circle back to nineteen sixty seven
where they had these very fancy
detectives for blood flow and xena and
we might actually have something at this
but instead of using pet we use optical
tomography so in summary I just wanted
to thank my many collaborators and all
of you for your time and I'm now ready
to take questions thank you dr. Wong for
that informative presentation before we
get started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you submit them
by typing them in Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button lower left of the presentation
window will try to answer as many
questions as we can our first question
dr. Wong what is the future of pet
imaging in regards to temple and spatial
resolution do you think that we could
use pet imaging in developmental studies
safely um so um I I would like to ask
the question about developmental studies
I presume they mean developmental
patient groups is that is that the the
question about developmental studies the
person who asked question did not
specify dr. one all abnormalities what I
did not show is we've we've had a number
of studies involving rett syndrome
lesch-nyhan syndrome we're collaborating
with people on the number of other
developmental disorders including autism
at the present time the local rules and
to some extent the FDA is more reluctant
to study people 18 below 18 years
although some studies have been carried
out with reduce radioactive doses at the
NIH by do to that poor than others the
last three slides that I showed you from
the brain initiative does not involve
any radioactivity so it's possible that
what if we were able to over the next
three years get this to work these dyes
would not involve any radioactivity and
might be useful in developmental
disorders thank you our next question
how early can we diagnose the early
stages of dementia and Alzheimer's
disease using pet imaging and can we
differentiate frontotemporal dementia
versus Alzheimer so regarding the first
question regarding the first question
about early stages there is a large
literature that's growing throughout the
world that there may be populations not
only people who have family histories
and a Polly certain a poet genotypes
where we can detect these people very
early on even with mild cognitive
impairment the amyloid imaging is a lap
is allowing us to understand
better it's not a perfect measurement
yet like most of these things but there
is a world right effort to try to do
early detection and in fact the
Baltimore longitudinal study the aging
studies I guess showed you as a number
of studies that have Illustrated these
that early stages can be determined and
I'll direct you to many of these sites
because there's a this if you just
pubmed search it you'll find literally
thousands of recent articles on this
field it's not I can't give a definitive
answer yet because it's still a work in
progress the question what frontal
temporal dementia versus a be it's not a
perfect relationship yet we think that
when we developed our imaging agents in
the future this may help certainly
Florida oxyglow glucose has been used
for frontotemporal dementia but with
amyloid towel and fdg it should be much
more we should be much better at being
able to differentiate ftv from
Alzheimer's for that that's a very good
question thank you our next question
what is your impression of the glycine
site partial agonist GL y X 13 for
depression it's in phase 2 clinical
trials right now I believe I'm afraid
that I'm afraid that I I can't answer
that because I'm not familiar with that
glycine site partial agonist at this
time I haven't worked with it and I
don't know anything about it
academically I think the main issue is
that with glycine glycine transporter
type 1 there's not only the roach
compounds that we published but there's
other tracers that are available to look
at the glycine transporter 1 and it's
and
I guess the question I would ask Pamela
Thompson is is it is it does it bind to
the glycine transporter site 1 and if
not it's a little harder to say what we
can do with it furthermore my imaging
studies that I illustrated are more
focused to dose-ranging as opposed to
efficacy thank you dr. wrong
unfortunately we are out of time I would
like to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event and our speaker dr.
Dean wang today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing for the
next few months you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time bye